Simplifying variables underneath a radical works the same way as it does for
factors, or just numbers. We'll look at simplifying the cubed root of x to the
fourth times y to the sixth. Keep in mind that these variables actually
represent numbers, like x could equal 2 and y could be 3. Our rules for these
won't change, we'll still apply the product rule if we can, and we can only
remove factors if they repeat three times. For example, we can split this up
into the cube root of x times x times x times x. These four xs are the same as
x to the fourth. Similarly, our second radical will have the cube root of y to
the sixth. Since our x variable repeats three times, we you can pull one of
them out, we can also pull out one y from these three, and one y from these
three. This x however is a little bit lonely, it doesn't have three of itself,
so we leave it inside the cube root. So our final answer is x times y squared
time the cube root of x. So in order to simplify any radical we want to take
the radican and split it up into its factors. If a factor appears the same
number of times as the index of the root, then that means we can pull one of it
out. That was why we could pull out one x, one y and one y. We multiply all
those factors together and leave any single or lonely factors inside of the
radical. This will give us our final answer.